l'absence de pluie on a donc moins de
pluie sécheresse inédite le conseil est
clair la France traverse une période de
sécheresse historique face à cette
situation le gouvernement envisage de
possible restrictions d'eau pour les
prochains mois alors va-t-on de voir se
priver d'eau cet été
cet hiver la France a connu une période
de sécheresse historique 32 jours sans
pluie soit la plus longue période de
sécheresse météorologique jamais
enregistrée les météorologues parlent
d'une sécheresse hivernale c'est-à-dire
d'un déficit de pluie par rapport à la
moyenne saisonnière d'après la chaîne
météo du premier au 21 février le cumul
de pluie moyen sur 30 villes de
référence a atteint 2,5 mm pour une
normalement Suelle de 52 mm si cette
sécheresse hivernale apparaît d'autant
plus inquiétante c'est précisément parce
que la pluie qui tombe de novembre avril
permet de remplir la phréatique et
d'humidifier les seuls en profondeur on
est dans une période critique puisque en
termes de déficit d'eau il nous manque
plus de deux mois de pluie à partir
d'avril avec l'essor de la végétation et
les premières chaleurs l'eau commence à
s'évaporer des sols et hydrate la flore
la végétation et la nature vont
reprendre leurs droits il faudra donc
que les nappes soient remplies si elles
ne le sont pas l'eau qui va tomber et
bien sera absorbé par les végétations et
ne pourra plus être utilisée pour
d'autres types d'utilisation ce déficit
plus géométrique s'élève aujourd'hui à
20%. en effet l'absence de pluie
hivernale vient s'ajouter à une année
particulièrement pauvre en plus sur les
18 derniers mois 15 ont été déficitaires
et le gouvernement annonce de possibles
restrictions dès le mois de novembre on
a commencé à parler de restriction d'eau
là où normalement on commence à parler
de ce type de mesures un peu extrême
autour du printemps voir au début de
l'été donc on n'a jamais connu des
sécheresses aussi précoces en France en
tout cas sur les 40 dernières années la
période qui vient s'annonce décisive la
recherche est nappe phréatique se fait
jusqu'à mi-abren mais un seul épisode
plus vieux ne suffira pas à parler cette
sécheresse il peut pleuvoir énormément
mais s'il pleut sur un sol qui est sec
c'est à dire qui n'est pas capable
d'absorber rapidement le volume d'eau
qui tombe et bien l'eau va tout
simplement ruisseler jusqu'à la mer et
ce sera de l'eau perdue en revanche si
il pleut sur un temps suffisamment long
et de façon régulière le sol a le temps
d'absorber l'eau qui tombe et surtout de
télécharger les nappes phréatiques et
c'est ça aujourd'hui dans la France a
besoin à ce jour quatre départements
sont déjà placés en alerte renforcée
l'un les Bouches-du-Rhône les
Pyrénées-Orientales et le Var or d'après
le ministre de la transition écologique
ce chiffre va inévitablement grimper
l'objectif du gouvernement reste
aujourd'hui d'anticiper pour éviter de
trop grande restrictions sur la
sécheresse on va sauter d'une
planification en la matière la nation a
besoin de faire sur l'eau comme on l'a
fait sur l'énergie une forme de plein de
sobriété c'est ce que je disais en fin
d'été c'est la fin de l'abondance l'été
dernier 700 communes ont déjà connu des
difficultés d'approvisionnement en eau
potable si la situation exige les
préfets sont en mesure de décider
localement de mesures exceptionnelles de
restriction de l'eau pour les
professionnels comme les particuliers le
niveau le plus haut d'alerte qui est le
niveau de crise prévoit justement qu'il
est secteurs prioritaires c'est la
sécurité civile à savoir l'utilisation
d'eau pour les incendies par exemple
mais aussi pour la santé et pour l'eau
potable évidemment en revanche
l'utilisation de l'eau pour l'irrigation
des sûr ou pour certains usages privés
peut-être limité alors a priori la
situation n'est pas suffisamment
critique pour qu'on soit privé d'eau
dans les maisons puisque l'accès à l'eau
potable fait partie des secteurs
prioritaires qui sont définies en cas de
crise et qu'au niveau actuel des nappes
phréatiques nous aurons de l'eau pour
les âges privés cet été mais dans les
prochaines années la quantité d'eau
disponible va largement décroître selon
le GIEC la masse hydrique des cours
d'eau en France devrait réduire de 10 à
40% d'ici 2050 c'est un niveau qui est
déjà prévu et auquel les agriculteurs
les Français vont devoir s'habituer et
pour lequel ils vont devoir adapter
leurs pratiques et leurs habitudes pour
pouvoir vivre aussi bien mais avec moins
d'eau
[Musique]